une start-up saint-quentinoise ocs 2017
de las vegas sky one portal est engagé
dans le secteur de la réalité virtuelle
pour sa deuxième participation consumer
electronic show
les attentes sont importantes ils
s'élèvent pour nous c'est vraiment une
occasion de tisser des liens avec des
grands industriels de faire connaître
notre savoir-faire dans le meilleur des
cas mais quelques contrats avec des
industriels
c'est ce qui est arrivé dernière donc là
on va voir ce que ça va donner
et on a des retombées en termes de
communication c'est une grosse mise en
visibilité de disco fait l'idée c'est
que le maximum de personnes puissent
tester la solution c'est celle de la
technologie quelle technologie assez
novatrice pour la réalité virtuelle
orienté grand public
deux installations seront accessibles
aux visiteurs du cs avec peut-être des
contrats à la clé créé en 2013 cette
start up est installé à montigny le
bretonneux dans la pépinière
d'entreprises promo paul olivier legrand
avec emmanuel écart et julien bassens
ont voulu démocratiser les systèmes de
réalité virtuelle pour les particuliers
là le fait qu'il ya un capteur je vais
pouvoir être actif avec le monde
numérique c'est à dire qu'il veut
pouvoir sélectionner par donc ici des
jeux donc là c'est un jeu qu'on a
développé le
le but étant d'éviter les obstacles et
d'attraper les ballons jaunes deux
projecteurs pour le mur et le sol un
capteur de mouvement ce système est
aussi utile pour les entreprises
industrielles
oui typiquement font des visites
d'appartements à l'échelle 1 ou alors
fondé revue numérique de leurs projets
pour faire des validations d'avancement
de projets d inventer validation de
jalons justement dans les revues
numérique par rapport à la conception de
nouveaux bâtiments pour ce système de
réalité virtuelle comptait vingt mille
euros destinés aux particuliers le
système skalli atteint les 5000 euros en
2016 sky one portal compte près de 30
systèmes déployés dans le monde